we're determined to discover traces of
Life on remote exoplanets so we cast our
gaze far beyond the boundaries of the
solar system and into the great abyss of
space
but actually just several hundred years
ago
a unique world was detected
comparatively close to us
there are clouds in its atmosphere it
rains there and on its surface great
rivers flow into lakes and seas
still the conditions on this fascinating
Celestial body are lethal
with a surface Bound by incredible cold
so what is really happening on Titan
Titan is located about 10 astronomical
units from the Sun and is outside the
habitable zone of our star
it is Saturn's largest satellite at its
orbit lies well outside the gray trains
at a distance of about 1 million two
hundred thousand kilometers from the
center of the planet
the trajectory of the celestial body is
close to Circular and a complete orbit
around the gas giant takes a little less
than 16 Earth days
Titan's diameter is
5152 kilometers which is 5.6 percent
larger than that of Mercury
at the same time the mass of the
celestial body is relatively small at
only 1.35 times 10 to the power of 23
kilograms
which is about 40 percent of mercuries
calculations show that the satellite's
average density is about three times
less than that of the earth which means
it has a completely different chemical
composition
according to contemporary Concepts Titan
has a massive core at its Center about
3400 kilometers in diameter and made up
of various silicon compounds
it is surrounded by thick layer of
densely packed ice which is at the
bottom of a cold liquid ocean hundreds
of kilometers deep
the ocean in its turn contains large
amounts of dissolved ammonia methane and
various caustic salts
so that its freezing point is markedly
lower than that of ordinary water
for this reason
Titans subsurface ocean remains liquid
even in Sub-Zero temperatures
it is bound by thick crust around 100
kilometers thick consisting of a mixture
of water ice and methane hydrate
the tidal forces of the nearby Saturn
are continuously deforming it causing
massive Rifts and fractures
this causes large cryovolcanoes to form
ejecting great quantities of methane
ammonia and water onto the surface of
the celestial body
methane plays about the same role in
Titan's atmosphere as water vapor on
Earth
the fact is that the average surface
temperature of the satellite is only
about 94 Kelvin or 179 degrees Celsius
below zero which is slightly below its
boiling point natural variations in this
parameter cause hydrocarbon Vapors to
condense and precipitate forming methane
Seas lakes and rivers
Titan's atmosphere is composed mainly of
hydrogen which makes up about 98.4
percent of its volume while methane
accounts for about 1.6 percent due to
its extremely low temperature the
satellite's atmosphere remains condensed
near its surface and the Ring of the
mountains surrounding it is less than
500 meters high
most of the surface of the celestial
body is permanently obscured from our
eyes by multi-layered clouds and an
orange yellow soul in Haze this unique
weather phenomenon is a fog formed by
tiny droplets of liquid methane and
dissolved organic matter which gives
Titan its characteristic Hue this Haze
pervades Titan's surface absorbing and
scattering visible light but
transmitting infrared light this
peculiarity leads to an unusual
anti-greenhouse effect which cools the
satellite's Surface by roughly another
10 degrees
this effect makes Titan difficult to
explore but thanks to the cassini's
orbiter's infrared cameras Titan was in
Parts mapped out earlier this century
of course it is not as accurate as we
would prefer but even this much is
enough to outline the most striking
features of the celestial body's surface
the face of Saturn's largest moon is
full of contrasting spots
some of these reflect Mouse to the light
that falls on them While others are
relatively dark in color
one such area is slightly south of the
Equator and is called Aslan
one of Titan's highest mountains Mount
Doom or Doom mons is located here
towering about one and a half kilometers
above the surrounding Plains
the hell Mountain reaches up to 60
kilometers in diameter its Summits are
craters and its slopes have relatively
fresh traces of turbulent flows this may
suggest that doomans is an active cryo
volcano
to the Northeast from it is Titan's
deepest depression called satrapatra
it has a giant depression about 30
kilometers long the bottom of which is
located about two kilometers below the
adjacent Plains
it is thought to be the mouth of a huge
cryo volcano and is part of a single
tectonic structure along with do mons
located close by
to the north of Dum mons there stretches
the immense mahini fluctus a vast area
covered by Doom monza's ejections
the area extends for about 180
kilometers and varies in width from 15
kilometers in the South to 60 kilometers
in the North
where torrents of Frozen material
ordinate with expansive fields of sand
dunes consisting of a mixture of Frozen
methane and Water Ice
our flight will continue over the dark
area of fencil
the largest impact crater of the
celestial body Minerva is located in its
Northwestern part it reaches 440
kilometers in diameter which is about
three times larger than any other crate
on Titan
the depression is about 200 meters deep
and the Ring of the mountains
surrounding it is less than 500 meters
high
the fact is that according to studies
Minerva is not only the largest but also
the eldest extant crater on Titan
different estimates put the age of the
crater at between 300 million and 1.2
billion years erosion and tectonic
processes have severely damaged the
crater and it is only thanks to its
sheer size that it is still visible
Minerva has a well-defined internal
structure
at its Center there is a small flat
plane surrounded by a ring of hills
this region with a total diameter of
about 200 kilometers is rather light and
clearly visible from space it is
surrounded by so-called moats a stretch
of dark Plains about 50 kilometers wide
this is followed by a ring of low
mountains that form the outer boundary
of the crater
our flight next takes us to the South
here is one of Titan's most impressive
and mysterious landmarks Jose Arcus
this is a unique formation in the solar
system
it is a bright arc-shaped region about
600 kilometers long
radar data from Cassini shows that hote
Arcus is a natural boundary between the
Rocky Mountains in the Northeast and a
wide Valley in the northwest
it is also noteworthy that some parts of
this area change color from time to time
this phenomenon is thought to be linked
to the eruptions of cryovolcanoes whose
emissions cover the surface of the
satellite in a thin layer and then flow
into a nearby Valley or evaporate into
the atmosphere
from space one can clearly see light
channels similar to riverbeds running
from the mountains of the hotel Reggio
to the Northwest this is where Xanadu is
located which is a vast lowland area
with highly rugged terrain
Northwest boundaries formed by
mithrimontes which are three parallel
ridges stretching for about 150
kilometers with an average height of 1.9
kilometers
among the peaks of the Southern range is
the highest peak on Titan reaching
3337 meters
standing on top of it and looking West
you can see a vast dark plane stretching
several hundred kilometers in front of
you
it is called Shangri-La and it is
thought that this whole area used to be
flooded with liquid methane it is
assumed that it may have persisted
beneath the topsoil similar to the
Earth's underground water most of this
region is below average elevation and
has a comparatively flat terrain but
lighter Hills can be seen in some places
in the past these may have been islands
in the middle of a hydrocarbon sea
to the west of Shangri-La is the bright
adiri Upland area clearly visible
against dark regions around it
the area extends for up to two and a
half thousand kilometers and is a
veritable network of numerous drainage
canals and caves clearly visible in the
photographs
these are thought to have been formed by
Abundant flows of liquid hydrocarbons
to the west of adiri is the vast dark
lowland area of balat
and to the east near the border with
Shangri-La is the highgens landing site
so far the only vehicle that got touched
down on the surface of an object in the
outer solar system
The Descent probe was part of a science
program called Cassini Huygens
together with the Cassini automatic
probe it left Earth in 1997 to spend
seven years in interplanetary space
the spacecraft entered the orbit of
Saturn early in 2004 and in early 2005
Huygens reached Titan and plunged into
its atmosphere towards new discoveries
Cassini on the other hand remained in
orbit around a gas giant to carry out
its part of the research program as well
as to continue serving as a transponder
for the Lander
the probe spent just under two and a
half hours in the atmosphere
gradually dropping speed using a
sophisticated parachute system
eventually by the time it touched down
on the surface its speed was 4.4 meters
per second the probe successfully
withstood a momentary 15-fold overload
and soon went on to collect information
Huygens was equipped with a vast array
of scientific instruments most of which
were designed to study different aspects
for the satellite's atmosphere the probe
used them to measure the strength and
direction of air currents as well as the
electrical conductivity temperature and
composition of the atmosphere
the probe also took photographs and made
audio recordings and on Landing it
examined the composition and properties
of the ground
the first thing the cameras saw after
making contact with the surface was a
flat plane dotted with rounded rocks of
various sizes the shape of which clearly
indicated the impact of powerful fluid
currents a special drill was also used
to sample the surface penetrating 15
centimeters into the ground while
multiple sensors measured its density
texture and composition
turned out that a thin layer of small
rounded Pebbles lay on a relatively soft
but dense substrate
similar inconsistency to wet sand or
dense snow also methane gas was released
during the drilling process
the ground of the Huygens Landing site
is believed to have been like sea sand
saturated with liquid hydrocarbons
in total the probe transmitted around
500 megabytes of information to Earth
including 350 photographs
further careful analysis revealed
several unique features of the celestial
body related to its atmosphere
for example it turned out that at an
altitude of about 80 kilometers there is
a layer of almost complete calm
as if separating Titan's atmosphere into
two parts
neither air currents of the upper
atmosphere nor Winds of the surface
reach this layer
what caused this phenomenon is not yet
known
another feature is that Titan has two
ionospheres
the first of these is located at an
altitude of about 1200 kilometers
it is a layer of heightened electrical
conductivity with a large concentration
of ionized particles
this layer is known to be formed by
Stellar Wind streams and Cosmic
radiation
the second ionosphere lies much lower at
an altitude of about 60 kilometers and
the reason for its formation is still
debatable
moving Northwest from the adiri area
will reached Titan's largest hydrocarbon
Reservoir the Kraken Mare
its total area reaches 400 000 square
kilometers which is slightly smaller
than the Black Sea due to the high
viscosity of the liquid hydrocarbon
mixture it has not yet been possible to
measure the exact depth of the reservoir
it is only known that in most of the
area it is over 200 meters
another large natural Basin the liegea
mare is located slightly to the North
near Titan's Pole
its diameter reaches 500 kilometers and
its area is about a hundred thousand
square kilometers which is about three
times larger than Lake Baikal the seas
are connected to each other by the
narrow and long Travis fretum 173
kilometers long
also in the South polar region there are
many smaller lakes and lagoons filled
with liquid methane
in 2014
analysis of earlier images beamed back
by Cassini revealed a large bright
object on the surface of the lygium air
on comparing photographs taken at
different times it was established that
within a few months the mysterious
object had grown to 260 kilometers in
diameter to disappear almost instantly
Without a Trace
several hypotheses have been put forward
to explain it according to one of them
temperature differences lead to a
constant staring of layers of liquid
hydrocarbon mixture in the large GM air
this causes nitrogen bubbles to form and
rise to the surface from the depths of
the reservoir
and thus form large clusters of
persistent shiny foam due to the high
viscosity of the hydrocarbons
such bubbles can reach 4.5 centimeters
in diameter and remain stable for months
from space these structures resemble
large islands because they reflect
infrared radiation well
such bubbles would have been a
significant hindrance to the operation
of a submersible probe which was
scheduled to be launched to tighten back
in 2010.
however the mission was postponed
indefinitely for various reasons a
higher priority was given to the
dragonfly program which NASA is working
on now
the vehicle is currently in the design
phase and has just recently passed key
tests with blades
the launch from Earth is scheduled for
2027.
as conceived by its creators dragonfly
will be a noctocopter an aircraft with
four twin propellers
this design will allow it to stay in the
air even if it loses several blades
unlike its predecessor the Ingenuity
Mars helicopter
a radioisotope thermo generator powerful
enough to enable the vehicle to climb to
a height of four kilometers and travel
at a speed of about 36 kilometers per
hour will be used as the power source
the scientific capabilities of the probe
are also impressive it will be equipped
with a versatile camera capable of
producing both panoramic photographs or
the surrounding terrain and macro images
of the ground at the same time the mass
spectrometer will make it possible to
determine the chemical composition of
atmospheric samples and the internal
structure of rocks
perhaps dragonfly's data will help us
clarify an important question
do we at least have a chance of
encountering primitive life
the possibility of Life on Titan remains
hotly debated
on the one hand the extremely low
surface temperature the presence of
extremely toxic hydrocyanic acid in the
atmosphere and the absence of liquid
water would likely rule out the presence
of biological Life as We Know It
Titan's atmosphere on the other hand
exhibits an incredible diversity of
organic compounds
nitrogenous bases and amino acids which
are the building blocks of proteins RNA
and DNA could be naturally synthesized
on its surface
it is also known that liquid methane can
serve as a solvent and potentially play
the role of water in biochemical
reactions
in addition experiments show that under
certain conditions a mixture of liquid
hydrocarbons with phosphane forms an
environment similar to the primordial
soup of the early Earth
this means there's a chance of
encountering downright exotic forms of
life on the surface of the satellite
Titan is a unique World fascinating and
mysterious
winds and rainfalls are common on its
surface which is crossed by Rivers so
similar to those on the Earth but so
different at the same time
for all we know there is much more to
the universe than we can imagine and
it's not everywhere that life looks The
Way We Know It
could this phenomenon that we've been
painstakingly trying to detect on
trillions of planets around us
actually be pretty much in our backyard